انطلق يوم الخميس معرض جده للكتاب 2022
تحت قبه سوبر دوم جده برعايه وزاره
الثقافه وهيئه الادب والنشر والترجمه
وبالمشاركه اكثر من 900 دار نشر محليه
وعربيه ودوليه المعرض هو من ايام الاولى
شاهد اقبال كبير وتفاعل من الزوار
وفعاليات ومستمره حتى 17 ديسمبر وبتضمن
البرنامج الثقافي اكثر من 100 فعليه
وبتشمل الجلسات الحواريه والامسيات
الشعريه كمان ورش عمل واقتصاديه مجموعه من
المتحدثين السعوديين والتولين البارزين في
مختلف المجالات هذا كله بالاضافه الى
مجموعه من المناطق والاجنحه المتنوعه مثل
ركن خالص للمؤلف السعودي يشمل اكثر من 400
للمؤلفين ذوي النشر ذاتي واجنحه على الكتب
الصوتيه رقميه وجلسات ومناطق قراءه وغيرها
ركن اخر من اركان معرض جدي للكتاب الحالي
ملفت للانتباه وعمل تفاعل واسع هو منطقه
الخير العلمي المره الاولى اللي حدث عربي
من هذا النوع بخصوص منطقه كامله للخيال
العلمي فقط المنطقه مصممه بشكل اسباب
المركبه الفضائيه وبتضمن اركان تعريفيه
للادب الادب الخيال العلمي واللي بيلقى
رواج واهتمام كبير كثير عند مختلف شرائح
المجتمع بمختلف في فئه العمر كله بالاضافه
الى مجموعه من الفعاليات والانشطه ومن
ابرزها مؤتمر الخيال العلمي ايضا المؤتمر
كان من ايام مستمر يومين وهو الاول من
نوعه في السعوديه في تفاعلكم احنا حبينا
ناخذكم في الجو ولا في معرض الكتاب تحديدا
في هذه المنطقه اللي احنا عم نحكي عنها
منطقه الخيال العلمي فمعنى من مقر معرض
جده للكتاب مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد اهلا بك عبد الواحد همم يعني معرض
متميز على ما يبدو
همم اقسام جديده همم هذا العام مثل القسم
اللي عم نحكي عنه قسم الخيال العلمي حدثنا
اكثر واخذنا بجوله هيك خلينا نشوف هذا
القسم بعيوننا همم لانه بالفعل قسم متميز
راويه طبعا بالفعل في معرض الكتاب هذه
النسخه النسخه مختلفه من حيث الفعاليات
الثقافيه والاقسام المتنوعه اللي كانت
مختلفه بعض الشيعه السابقه تحديدا في
منطقه الخيال العلمي اللي تجاهدونها خلفي
هذا هو المدخل الخاص
بالمنطقه اللي همم يعني تشهد اقبال كبير
من همم مختلف الفئات هذه المنطقه يحضر
فيها يعني كل من هو مهتم بالخيال العلمي
فيها طبعا اقسام متنوعه مختلفه همم من
خلال المقتنيات اللي موجوده همم اللي هي
طبعا مقتنيات نادره من افلام ومسلسلات
خاصه
بالخيال العلمي اضافه الى الاقسام الاخرى
مثل همم
الشخصيات همم طبعا همم وكذلك حتى مساحه
القراءه الخاصه هذه هي الاقسام الثلاث
الرئيسيه الموجوده في هذا القسم وهذه
المنطقه لتقام لاول مره في معرض الكتب في
السعوديه همم في هذا المنطقه استديو صناعه
الشخصيات همم يتم همم العمل على همم تعلم
رسم الشخصيات همم المشاركين من الاطفال
حسب التكنيكات معينه همم معتمده طبعا في
هذا القسم همم تتم المشاركه بشكل مستمر من
قبل الاطفال المشاركين في هذه همم المنطقه
همم طبعا وكذلك هذه الجزيره في منطقه
الخيال العلمي همم اللي هي مساحه القراءه
همم اللي تعتمد القراءه الجماعيه تحديدا
للاطفال والموجودين في همم هذا القسم من
خلال مشاركه ما يقراون في معرض الكتاب في
هذه النسخه يعني هذه ابرز التفاصيل راويه
المتعلقه في هذه المنطقه تحدي المنطقه
العلميه
عن بقيه الاقسام حسب ما همم يعني عرفنا
بانه حتى هناك قسم خاص بالنشر الذاتي همم
يعني خصوصا الناشر السعودي اللي قام بنشر
الذاتي بعيدا عن دور النشر وهذه طريقه
جديده بالنشر يمكن همم احنا ما تعودنا
عليها
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا الجانب وجوانب اخرى
يعني متميزه في همم المعرض خصوصا الاقبال
عليه
مفهوم جديد في معارض الكتب همم موجود في
همم معرض جدا للكتاب مبادرات ومشاريع
السعوديه تعتمد همم نشر ذاتي من خلال همم
يعني الاعتماد بشكل مباشر واختصار مسافه
العمل من خلال العمل مع المطابع مباشره
دون الحاجه الى همم يعني وكلاء نشر وتجر
نشر وهذه السلسله الطويله هذه ال- ال- همم
يعني المبادره اللي موجوده في معرض جدا
الكتاب وكانت موجوده كذلك في معرض الرياض
يتم من خلالها تسهيل العمليه اكثر يعني
انا شفت بعض دور نشر الموجوده والمطابع
والمشاريع اللي موجوده اللي تعتمد فكره
النشره الذاتي همم يعني حتى في بعض
الاقسام يعني في قسم موجود هنا عنده حتى
الطابعات ويطبع في خلال عشر دقائق ممكن
تطلع النسخه همم اذا كان عندك حقوق همم
اضافه الى طبعا الفعاليات الثقافيه واللي
ما حكينا عنها يعني كان في همم
استثنائيه يعني مختلفه شويه يعني كان في
شخصيات همم تمت استضافتها من ممثلين من
مسلسل جيم اوف ثرونز وكذلك من سترينجرنجز
وغيرها من الفعاليات اللي موجوده يعني حتى
مثلا الفعاليات اللي كانت تناقش الافلام
سواء كانت الافلام السعوديه وحتى يعني
الافلام الاجنبيه الافلام الخيال العلمي
مؤتمر الخيال العلمي راويه كان يناقش كذلك
موضوعات لاول مره في همم يعني في هذه
النسخه من همم معرض جدا للكتاب
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الواحد الحميد مشاهدينا
كان معنا من مقر المعرض جده للكتاب شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]